[Music]
hello everybody my name is Marc Blair
and I'm very dizzy ah I was ready for
this Benoit since my rocking out days so
welcome to peace death now this game
which probably has the cool soundtrack
that I've seen - Milo okay I don't know
these oh hi so this is a game because
you guys presented the conundrum that I
find moral choices in games very
difficult when it comes to being a judge
jury and executioner but this game in
particular chair oh but you're going for
the chair there Oh No
okay alright then
yeah okay huh oh I see
this is funny because this game is
executing itself like a very specific
SCP it's weird like and that'll make
sense if you ever read the SCP about it
there's a certain SCP that you cannot
write think or talk about in any way the
only way you can get information about
it across is through symbols and
suggestions because otherwise oh hi
otherwise it'll come get you that's what
it'll do welcome to apocalypse a creeper
I'm your superior look around and get
down to work ah you gluttony ah you own
guard it's the plague doctor from SCP
wouldn't you know it I call this [ __ ]
okay what do I do
ah junior apprentice 30 client I don't
know how well I know I'm doing here so I
got a lot of Pez I got some coins I got
a hand coffee I don't know
oh hi it is your first day today Reaper
so here is a simple task that you won't
screw up okay alrighty then
Devil's must be sent to the left
elevator to hell people must be sent to
the right one to heaven now go ahead oh
sure can I take my axe with me sure go
ahead
hello
I think I'm doing great hurt me okay
will do okay I'm important cargo oh it's
funny okay okay okay I did it I did
great
I did gray I did good I actually did
good guys yeah oh did the Four Horsemen
of the Apocalypse
I didn't even know that was possible
hijack what are you doing here you all
right jack yeah okay
hello did I save you think maybe I did
all right one time effects Authority
additional it's except for Joe's in
Oregon why I don't even know what these
are I don't know what any of this is I
was thrust into a job that apparently
I'm incredible and I don't think I
wanted all right you know what I'm going
do yeah I'll do that one yeah that
sounds good to me and maybe okay all
right you know I'm gonna go for it huh
today other Reapers noticed a funny
thing and that's what I say Reaper
trying to send his demonic desmosomes to
heaven Lucifer began to endow people
with his demonic power and horns
from this day on everyone who wears a
horn should be sent to hell
good okay goodbye all right okay okay oh
boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
oh boy oh boy okay I don't have good
commentary or just an oboe over and over
again goodbye
Seattle I wish I could see what these
guys are saying to me the meaning of
life is to serve humanity
oh no save me from the Marines now you
go back in there oh okay okay okay okay
okay all right yeah I did it I'm amazing
I'm really good at this
I'm actually really I actually do like
these sort of things because I'm good at
pattern recognition that's one of the
things that I'm very good at about with
names I'm bad with remembering
short-term stuff but a pattern
recognition whoo hoo boy bebe are in
that [ __ ]
whoo that's all over my bag oh hey 200
years ago I invented a substance for
poisoning cockroaches but it's hand out
quite differently from what I expected I
instead of killing them it's reagent
made cockroaches grow and these giants
are now destroying the city doing Wars
job I need to deal with it as soon as
possible work the next day for me and
save my reputation today I shouldn't be
distracted reward after work okay cool
war war never changes I know myself I'm
100 and vegan I door broccoli with me
without the broccoli huh I'm not the
worst that can happen to men okay right
cool I think each client is one less
feature level of 60 seconds longer I
don't need that
not a point oh I clicked in the wrong
spot for that okay yeah sure okay all
right let's do this
today people starting to use weapons
Reaper just today it was the craziest
thing who had fought it certainly not I
weapons are those dangerous things they
have with them the way to heaven is
closed for them as famines mouth is
closed for healthy food then everyone
who gets you with fire armor ebbed
weapons to hell let's begin okay goodbye
hello goodbye goodbye alright you know
thank you okay I still got to remember
all just a game of Simon Says isn't it
no yep yeah no no no can you get out of
here with your weapons
no with your horns you're fine get in
there that's this weird you know go to
hell you gotta help you're gonna help
you go to heaven man the people go into
having her a lot less these days you
know he'll go to hell gay man go to hell
go to hell go to hell go to hell again
gonna hell [ __ ] no one's going to having
these days it's not a single goddamn
person's going to heaven at least I
gotta work for pestilence they're the
fear of many people living on the planet
has come to live the British scientist
working on a cure against influenza made
a mistake no doubt with pestilence has
helped and invented not what they wanted
it now London is steeped in a thick fog
and it is habited with zombies but it's
not too late reaper bidden yet
non-mutated people still will be saved
or rather the mutation will be postponed
he caught up with some Kyle crane follow
he needs our help in transporting the
working antidote we can't deliver it
ourselves but there is one fearless
courier service that is willing to
knew the gentleman it'll cost a bit of
money what do you say ah but why
reputation go down oh if I deny it
oh okay I don't know if there's a good
deal but sure it's for all our sakes
thank you okay I don't know what I
agreed to but okay all right you know
I'm just gonna go for it cuz I got
plenty of money and I alright
do you know Reaper that an average
person is up to five liters ooh blondie
some have it on themselves by the way in
order not to stain the white and pure
heaven those who are covered in blood
should be sin self
let's begin okay go ahead
No thank you no that's all right
you're not okay here go go go oh my god
I don't know why the purity of heaven
would be ruined by someone with blood it
could be all right you go Yao's another
tough call there call Dabhol all right
get here Lee get it Lee
good old Lee good early good Italy in
Italy early no yep yep nope go go go go
yep that almost looked like blood I
wasn't sure about that one homeboy I got
to remember everything one of these bad
boys
oh boy oh boy
God is getting harder and harder as time
goes on who'd have thought that a game
would be that way hey I'm a senior
apprentice I don't know how many ranks
arrow to climb but I'm gonna do one mo
of these they do war feel the fury of my
beers it okay all right you don't have
anything for me ah this is him haha
awesome
you know what is happening the
Confederates are concluding the truce
with the Federals and that's who our
advantage Reaper for the war for the
conflict will end in war will remain out
of work
but at the same time there's a
super-duper giant media flying to earth
to the same region I don't propose to
stop it because catastrophes are always
fun but we need to slow it down as much
as possible to make the media fall after
peace truce is signed as the loss is in
the result of such an event are not as
great as from the long war would you
like to buy front-row tickets to this
amazing show the contributions will be
sent to chromeless to create local time
dilation ah unfortunately I don't have
the money for that so sorry insult to
you yeah sorry about that
I don't need bees do this again hats and
headgear save the cold in the wind but
here has hinder our right decisions
everyone who comes here can use hats
side horns and horns or a feature of
he'll take off hats from clients to make
sure you can make the right decision
you're damned again okay no yeah sure
yeah take off people pass how am I
supposed to do that
Oh take off your hat no alright you
gotta go anyway you got blood anyway
excuse me get a de Leeuw doodly-doo go i
saw a weapon there a new awful
alright you're fine nope yep no no not
today
what that doesn't count in the Hat the
hood count is a handle all of that
Oh get out here you no no no no weapons
none of that you're fine somewheres
hares are rather well with that no go go
go oh you're fine hey I did it
actually pretty good at this they
legging not bad okay but anyway let me
finish out the week let me finish out
the week in the name of the Lich King
your eagerness to work knows no bounds
okay I'm gonna finish out the week here
one of the bloodiest days RIBA is today
there's so much blood so you need to
look everywhere even at the feet puddles
the blood left by the sinners are a
clear sign of the bad intentions
so the hell is really pong let's begin
also get ready for unexpected
catastrophes reaches there's a time
limit you'll figure it out
okay I'll go ahead no oh what's under
there no I see the blood nope No
what's gonna be easy if everyone's just
gonna hell already no no no yeah you're
fine you're fine you're fine
Oh No Oh what's under there doesn't
matter anyway I saw the blood oh no
Louis dicks on Jack the buzzer ripped it
off a cliff
what am I mean Oh No
uh you're fine again yep yep oh no no I
mean it goo
oh my first goop I can't believe it oh
man alright fine man
oh boy I had a perfect record I saw it
like a second too late ah man deeper
it's a nightmare tomorrow there's a
symposium on deadly diseases and I am
invited as the sole honorary lecturer
because no one can compete with my
intelligence and nobody else understands
old diseases as they do but the fact is
that I need someone to stay here would
you help me and work the next day for me
sir sergeant's grooves you to be the
rewarded to look okay I don't know what
that means but I'm gonna go and finish
out the week your first weekend Rita so
you work on weekends today we have a
surprise for you a theme day use your
accumulated knowledge surrounding by the
inhabitants of ancient Egypt and do your
job properly
go ahead all right oh okay
right you're fine also fine also fine
what's in the Hat now I see the logical
go cool okay this is gonna be a bit
difficult that Hatter okay I get blood
okay no blood go go go okay no idea what
something oh you tried to think that one
you're fine but you're trying to sneak
it on me not to talk man I thought way
too late Oh on a goon Fineman get out of
here go God Squad las' record what is
that a hat okay no all right you're fine
put her bird god you're fine you're not
fine you're not fine god dammit I was
gonna have a perfect week I got lazy on
the weekends
I'm a detective though so anyway oh hi
oh good good good good good good good
okay all right okay guess I got that I
did all right
point but anyway that is peace death an
interesting game a game of conscious and
quick wit and lightning reflexes which I
almost have even though like it's always
like a second lay the brain doesn't
register it but either way that was fun
so let me know what you think I did down
in the comments below maybe I'm just
barely above average or even average as
a bit but thanks again
and as always double see you in the next
video bye bye
[Music]